do you know how many Jews there are in
the world what the percentage of Jews in
the world me yeah do I know how many
Jews yeah you you'll have to know you
don't I would say it's 10% of 10% of the
population would of the world population
maybe
3% I I grew up in Long Island and now I
live in Beverly Hills So my answer when
somebody says how many Jews are it's
always too many because I come from Long
Island percentage of Jews in the world
is
0.18 that's wild there are okay let me
say this that's very few 14.9 or 15.1
depend on who you're count or what
you're counting million Jews in the
world so let's just go 15 right right
that's it wow that's it it's less than
the population of LA that's it yeah
that's it in the entire universe and Jew
and the Israel is the only Jewish State
Israel is the only Jewish State there
are 21 Arab State give us a [__]
break that's what we've been saying
we're like relax on this we are a
minority we are a margin okay to look at
the context of it like I fully think
that the Hamas attack was barbaric and
that Israel has a right to defend itself
that's 100% the case does Israel have
the right to exist I believe so great
then by the way to your viewers you're a
Zionist well I don't know well but
here's the thing I will say you're just
afraid of that word also hang on hang on
you just let's just talk about that word
for a second because that word was taken
away from us to mean something different
but they won't let me host a Daily Show
why I don't know but if they do I'll be
a Zionist but they to do with any give
me a test they won't even give me a test
how how come what why not I don't know
what does that have to do with to the
cabal no I'm kidding talk to the cabal I
mean can I tell you one more thing I've
been saying this for like two years I've
been joking I'm like they keep saying we
have a cabal may as well start acting
like we [__] do